did a blue correspondent Phoebe Kong is
in the city she caught up with Joshua
Wong for his take on these protests yeah
the questions are you confident that the
people power of Hong Kong can finally
defeat
Beijing scribbler in this movement I
have no hope to us the regime but I've
hoped to as people I believe when more
than millions of Hong Kong people or
even one-fourth of the citizen in my
hometown join this fight the government
can't ignore it
we're waiting for the miracle and
turning something impossible to be
possible and how do you find it what do
you think as activist and the protester
what what should they do in the next for
the next step to pressure action
demonstration rarely is the way out we
continue to put pressure on the
disappear leader of Hong Kong and do it
well when you're in the prison now I
know you watch the other sites you know
million people talk on the street so
what is your feeling how do you tell us
about the is shareable when I watch DW
news inside prison I recognize how
international communities keep the ice
in Hong Kong it's really impressed and
others show that how the spirit of
common people let the work to know that
we will not keep silence under the
hotline rule of President Xi Jingping
carry limbs and she actually apologized
to the public last night and do you
think this is enough and what what are
you like going for if she doesn't step
down then what would you do different
Carol I'm apologize it's useless because
damage has done by how she endures
police Jota can should to his activists
now it's the time for Caroline step down
prayer the political responsibility
withdraw any plan to prosecuted activist
leader and that's what we asked for and
do you feel regret that you actually
missed two of the biggest rally in Hong
Kong not only regret or missing the two
significant demonstration shopping Java
sentence it's the burden that I need to
face but I successfully overcome it
Joshua Wong they're interviewed by DW
correspondent Phoebe Kong now he along
with other protesters are also demanding
that Hong Kong leader Carrie Lam stepped
down she had the government that
protesters see as pro-beijing since
demonstrations began on Hong Kong
streets the government has gone from
unrelenting to combative to
concessionary and finally to apologetic
here is a selection of how Carrie Lam
has changed her tone in the space of
seven days there's very little merit to
be gained to or delay the bill it will
just cause more anxiety and divisiveness
in society I have not received any
instruction or mending from Beijing
any violence will not be tolerated by
our enforcement authorities whole
thing's a medium-high whopping subway
yeah I come in I also take comfort on
boat on neck Tom Holland
after repeated internal deliberations
over the last two days I now announce
that the government has decided to
suspend the legislative amendment
exercise but I have to admit that our
explanation and communication work has
not been sufficient or effective we will
adopt the most sincere and humble
attitude to accept criticisms and make
improve a promise to make improvements
but is it too little too late reporter
unfriendly myself from Hong Kong has
been monitoring protests for the past
week I'm sure welcome how does one
interpret what Carrie Lam has said it's
been quite a turnaround within a space
of seven days yes it is but I am Carrie
Lam just had to soften her tone because
for persistence to push through the law
there had been three different big
protests and on the first protest 1
million people came out and that she
didn't apologize
and then there was violent clash on the
second protest and then she still didn't
apologize and that's why it led to the
big protest yesterday so she just has
too soft in her tone now some people are
asking the question whether this is just
buying time a lot of demonstrators say
the and that Beijing is just buying time
that it will push through it because the
bill has just been suspended and not it
has not been withdrawn however some
government officials also say that the
bill is literally dead because any
amendments or cons the new consultation
works will have to be done before July
next year before the term of the
Legislative Council ends so that's why
some governments also say that the bill
is literally dead if the bill is
literally dead what does that mean for
Carrie lamps tenure is her tenure also
effectively over well Beijing has
actually announced official support for
her and some senior government officials
also said that even if Carrie Lam wants
to step down Beijing will not let her
step down
I guess we're Beijing it's just too much
of risk if there is a change in
leadership right now it will cost even
more instability to hong kong i think
this is
what Beijing wants to avoid right now
however this is considered to be a
defeat for Carrie Lam so some people
some experts say that it is very
unlikely that she will be able to serve
a second term this entire issue is not
over from the sound of it
I'm currently thank you very much for
coming into the studio and breaking that
down for us